what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Chucky two by seven today join with me
is John how are you John I am excellent
sir how are you doing great thanks for
asking ladies and gentlemen leave a like
you know how to do that slash that like
button also be sure to subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction to the finale
of Chucky is up here on the channel and
it's kind of been in the works for a
while obviously hasn't you know affected
our viewing experience we were not shy
to criticize but apparently we might be
getting the interview with Don Mancini
that we've been trying to get so yay yay
hopefully you didn't see the episodes we
were kind of critical and also a full
interaction watch along with your own
copy of Chucky available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page cover a
bunch of shows over there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included alrighty gang let's
swing the action and see where this goes
it's my fault
my dad
Devin's mom
Gary
and they did
I kind of blame you for Nadine yeah at
least that one yay
or good Chucky
crashing Comfort the lad because
violence is pure it's glorious I'm sorry
Jake good guy dolls are hard to come by
in fact this is the last one and I'm
gonna need it for Chucky Prime I think
we should talk about that
oh hell yeah it's all coming together
when all is said and done I am leaving
here with Charlie not with Nika's body
you're not agreed I think we've all seen
how messy things get when Chucky tries
to occupy a human body
plastic is much more resilient than
flesh yeah Nica Pierce is downstairs
she's a hostage in her own body Chucky's
hostage no different than if he had a
gun to her head if we can save Nika
that's what we're gonna do
okay
worse than the gun to your head
I'm sorry you're talking about an
exorcism
another Bryce
I think you're about to become
uncharacteristically useful you're the
perfect candidate the chuck circist
let's do this authorities believe that
Tilly bled her Beverly Hills Home a week
ago after allegedly setting it up can
you speed it up I'm in a little bit of a
hurry I'm in a hurry voice is too
recognizable no it's not it is
no no no I get that all the time but I'm
not her I promise although I am a fan of
her incredible bodies work wait you're
the murderer
yes but I'm not
oh God oh my God that's a terrible
picture turn it off hey can I get a pic
no no no oh my God
kill everyone there I need to transfer
my soul again but I can only transfer it
into a bell doll I go back to being
Jennifer Tilly now that Jennifer Tilly
is a criminal on the lamb I don't make
the rules Dom Bela does besides you've
already been behind bars for many years
now prison will be a walk in the park
for you there's a step up at least
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's not going to stop until we're all
dead together we can do anything
together we don't do anything together
anymore except fail to stop Chucky from
killing people
it's a fair point any of us actually
have anything in common besides Chucky
do you guys even like each other anymore
I couldn't answer any of her questions
nope you all seem more divided than ever
okay
Always On Cue
Always On Cue
don't trust those pills don't trust
anything that Chucky gives you drink
okay what's going on
oh
his delivery for good Chucky is
beautiful I need to call the Vatican for
approval and we'll all have to make our
confession beforehand
won't work unless we're pure
would you be so kindness to join me I'd
be happy to father
I'm terrified to call the Vatican hi
Andy Barkley I'm Nika Pierce oh my God
you actually met whoa
but you're a Chucky at the time
first is colliding if it works
it's right out of here with Dr mixtor
how do we know Chucky Prime is for sure
the one in Nika
that's an excellent question
they think it's the last one but maybe
not
what Lexie said about us not having
anything in common
you don't think that to you
later
I don't know I'm sorry I love Nadine too
are you sorry
but that's all you got to say
not sorry
oh
Jake
what happened he's like Nica
[Music]
not the kitties frolicking in the
daisies oh my that one's my favorite hey
Dean you're dead
well that's not a very nice thing to say
even if it is true
ah that Cape is everything but there
must be a reason why I'm here
oh my God is she OD
D
yep probably I'm sorry I couldn't save
you we all go to that big old amusement
park in the sky eventually
I just got my ticket early
but if you want my advice talk to Jake
and Devin they're your friends good
friends can make it through anything I
can't tell anyone that I have a problem
they would totally judge me probably at
first you already did you told me
but that's different
but you were strong you are Lexi
cross
I know you can do it they
we all deserve a friend like Nadine
start with I saw Nadine the angel and
here's what she told she told me to say
this now that there's a chance that I
might finally be rid of him
I'm ashamed to say it but
that terrifies me who are you without
Chucky so I've been excommunicated they
can't we have to do something we need
another plan something
gotta break into the Vatican
exorcism for dummies
we're going rogue yes
[Laughter]
get the Chucky body
as one In-Shape priest
these are very
you know that oh my God
oh
this truth you're absolutely right
you could kill yourself with these
and you're going to
oh I really want to know is why the
truth is you got a raw deal kid but
first I need you to go get my old Bowie
knife no enough you're exactly like Mom
this conversation is way too loud
I've been trying to understand you both
for so long that I couldn't even see
that Glenn and I are actually just
orphans
oh damn you are my kid you are a killer
and you can't escape that
watch me they choose their own
identities
watch me aggressively not kill can you
say a prayer for my twin Glenn you want
me to pray for them
pray for their soul this priest respects
pronouns he does woke priest he respects
pronouns but he is not too happy about a
gay relationship so
this works are going to be gone for good
will I go to heaven
can I hear please go to purgatory
I'm talking with him Jake you knew that
Chucky for like two days yeah
in the name of the father
son
and of the holy spirit amen
amen
amen
the Father the Son of the Holy Ghost
you think I'm scared to go to hell
yeah
I'm from Jersey
let's get some head turning we'll figure
something out being a doll is where it's
at I'm glad I'm happy that I can live
where I want do what I want and buy
thousands of pairs of tiny shoes
come on Jen
become the killer Jen Glenda and I never
got any choices you took them away from
us
[Music]
hey
run child
thank you
no
oh
no what
Jennifer Tilly oh
oh we just got Jennifer oh that's a
bummer that's her soul has to transfer
somewhere
I'll be 72 Jennifer Tilly's oh man
be going all hostile Powers go have
mercy on us and him
your mother sucks in Hell the Axel says
yes
the memories in this room dead
babysitter dead mom dead dad dead
friends dead family it's a lot of
memories damn it's a whole kill count in
there
[Music]
[Applause]
we go yup yup yup
check don't listen to him Jake
I'm here get a room
wait you had one and all you did was
fight
over me he makes a good point get out
unclean spirits
be gone unclean spirits
what the
what is this
don't get that close he's gonna bite
your nose
I come
no
[Music]
oh damn there it goes Prime Chucky
Unleashed damn it
having an exorcism without me
no see a little help here I need that
body
hey come on I'll be good
[Music]
you have to punch me
here cover my eyes
what kind of kid sends her dad to Hell
huh
an abandoned one and you're supposed to
be the tough one
tough
it's tougher than you can imagine Chuck
[Music]
if Christ compels you you're all gonna
die
the power of Christ compels you
oh damn
some full odd Exorcist yep
hey man go big go big or go to hell
[Applause]
he's gonna start flying around
gonna be a big black soul cloud
guy was waiting
father
oh no
it transferred to him just like the
Exorcist damn it
I'm like six feet tall
[Music]
Chucky
jump out the window
your first father
oh [ __ ]
oh my God whoa
oh my God
every possible oh my God
wow you know we get in trouble on
YouTube for showing that
wow but it was glorious
laughs
the church has always been a refuge for
people like me
never fully accepted us either Reese
I always known I was
different oh no
gays yep
that's a good way to quench those urges
I guess on on so many levels when you
had that kind of conflict and you know
you know you're gonna be at odds with
everyone else
what's my penance
nothing
saw was episode yeah boy
I think you've punished yourself more
than enough
I like her form of Catholicism I would I
would I would follow her
I don't know she's great I go back to
Catholicism for her oh damn
bring him back for season three I know
who's he gonna play next here
can we wrap this up a man just died no a
man just exploded
and may I remind you all we have a deal
they're just let them walk out come on
I hate myself
for failing to stop them
hatred is a sin that poisons us from the
inside I've lived
with this poison inside of me every day
slightest blue in her eyes
and now it's time to get it out
so good
give me the power I beg of you
[Music]
what are you doing
I was good to you Chucky I can't be
Chucky Prime
[Applause]
damn it Lexi and your stupid drugs Ethan
science team up you're this close Lexi
just let her go damn Jake didn't know
you had it in you been working out
[Music]
see you real soon
stop right there harbinger of sin
instrument of blasphemy it's a really
pretty good looking babe I was right
about that Blondo Lord
I am your servant I will
nicely done
Glenda yes
look upon your flock
Eye of the Beholder you know you could
have done that earlier Glenda oh
they do love each other and they have
even more trauma to bond over this time
it's personal
yeah I get that high frame rate
obviously moving so fast
all that prey and fixed his leg
oh
[Music]
great shot not bad Andy
[Music]
run child
oh
God that tongue hanging out guys
laughs dude the platoon yeah
she's paying tribute to a lot of movies
Andy Wick
do you think his whole life is flashing
before his eyes
if it is I'm sure he thinks he's having
the last laugh
[Music]
yeah that's brutal yeah
even on a doll yeah that's really brutal
damn couldn't have transferred the soul
into the doctor I certainly didn't look
that way what is the fake out
maybe his soul is just in The Ether
right now now they get to have what
Chucky stole from us yeah
now all they have to worry about is acne
gym class and heartache
and Trauma
withdrawals and persecution
no way
child's play DOS
damn how far we've come where are we
going
to a lifetime of misery and running I
honestly didn't know who said you were
even on
I'm on my own side
[Music]
always where's all the other students
is set them all on a field trip today
[Music]
I threw a knife
I had to spend way too much time with
Mom dad's dead
oh damn now mom's dead too
oh no oh oh
please
for my kids don't kill me please what do
they want say the word guys
no
no
oh Glenn you are too good oh no no we
need the doll we need the doll what
Collette into the doll
and we have to go
oh boy
oh poor Nika Jessica Nika thought she
was done with it horror I am going to
unleash Chucky on the world all over
again you have sworn your holy
absolutely nothing you can do to stop
stop do you truly believe in eternal
life father I know you preach it
I believe with certainty and I know it's
true Source
I guess did
dang they transfer
Charles E Ray is a good actor I guess
so was Chucky Prime in her the whole
time or was there a transference
that is the question I guess it would
certainly appear as though there was the
transference but maybe she was uh
yeah
chucked from the get-go can't get rid of
that Chucky man never just can't do it
nope
uh well what are you gonna do you can't
it just happens man yeah [ __ ] happens it
happens out here in these Chucky streets
what did you think John point out all
the Easter eggs oh yes you know what
you're here for yeah that's right make
yourself of service point out the Easter
references to Cult of Chucky the the
repeated obviously the voodoo uh you
know give me the power I think more
clarity please for our audience okay so
we got our references to platoon
obviously complimenting the war theme of
the past season with certain characters
including the colonel then we got the
requisite various references in Easter
eggs moments pulled directly from The
Exorcist we got the Pea Soup vomit we
got the levitation we didn't get a head
spin but we did get uh you know the
possession of the priest uh and then we
also got references to Cult of Chucky
and references to references please be
more specific specific speak of Chucky
support group they mentioned a Chucky
support group which is a subtle nod to
Cult of Chucky obviously the voodoo uh
prayer to dambala from the original
movie that appears in every Chucky
property is recited multiple times here
I believe they may have translated it in
French although I don't speak French
myself so I couldn't tell you for
certainly how is this a real Easter that
would play into the speaking of tongues
of various exercising stories then there
was also obviously footage taken from
Child's Play 2 and references to her
parents making them cynical obviously
they grew up in a foster home together
but maybe that could be an even deeper
reference into the character uh as well
we had Jennifer Tilly uh returning from
the Bride of Chucky and onward uh giving
her last performance in this episode
ostensibly as uh Tiffany the doll the
version uh so you know she's dead now
and uh Glenn and Glenda we did see the
doll for a split second although they
didn't make much out of it so you know
but that's still Seed of Chucky uh
referenced and name checked in here and
uh that's the Easter eggs that I have of
for Chucky season two episode seven
and the Lord we receive films now got
them all here yes
good job John right bringing back guns
to Chucky and previous episode he said
he's been killed by fire guns and big
industrial fans here we saw him gunned
down uh pretty uh you know calling back
to those previous gun deaths of Chucky
certainly uh the jaw getting ripped off
I'm sure is like a horror movie I'm
trying to there there are multiples you
could draw to but that is a kind of
particularly horror movie thing to do
this is a general Easter egg not really
an Easter egg at all it's more of just a
general reference 80s action movie
cliche with instead of a building
blowing up it's a person's body that's a
true yeah with all the different
multiple angles also uh you know getting
fired from your vocation usually caught
but here priest by the Vatican and then
going rogue and doing some kind of cool
suiting up Montage when you're about to
go Rogue it's good
it's good uh homage yeah also you know
the various I I just I want to know who
I really hope there are actual
characters operating the Bell and the
organs because there is an organ and a
bell so you know you always got your
requisite you know Gothic Phantom of the
Opera you know church music when you're
in there
and Pinocchio with the Blue Fairy of
Nadine so nod to Pinocchio her fairy
godmother who sends Lexi out to be a
real girl
yeah it's true
damn it's a Ruth fun yeah sister Ruth's
uh you know also recognize her subtle
nod to various non-exploitation movies
of the 70s as well now you're reaching
uh I'm probably just had a gun that was
it John it's still none exploitation she
she acted all cool
sure sure yeah that's what they were
saying on set this is uh it's very
important this is non-exploitation right
here definitely are no exploitation shot
yeah that was a good episode that was uh
it was a really entertaining one that
was it this is the full hardcore blown
religious horror episode and uh I'm glad
we got to that point where everything
comes collapsing and really it's like
Devin sabo's episode like the exorcism
scene really stands out
Devin Sawa uh really gotta shine I think
this was his best performance he's given
out of all of the Chucky Series combine
all three characters and here you get a
full flesh character you know having his
confession scene be something that
brought a lot of gravity to us to his
character I thought was
really impactful actually I thought it
made it more or it hit a lot harsher
when you when the fact that he did die
and he really gave it his all like you
understand why his commitment to this
was so strong and why his judgment was
also so strong so it's cool that they
actually got to give him a character arc
when I did not see a character are
coming at all for this dude and to do it
all in like one episode where you're
like oh damn this makes the whole idea
of re-experiencing this that much more
rewarding I thought was great
um and huh what what can I interject one
thing
before you move on from that yeah why
not yeah sure go for it yeah I think so
it's really cool I thought they did it
yeah definitely a nice version I agree
so when it comes to this that's the
character of priest
father price
um so with his character words out of my
mouth
the way every Exorcist movie has the
priest who's conflicted within his faith
I thought they actually did a really
nice Twist on that in that that was the
case but we don't really know that till
later
it's like a good way to incorporate a
well-worn Trope but in a way that is
much more impactful than usual yeah I
thought it was funny when he called the
Vatican and they just fired universe
yep understand now Max communicate going
rogue
well it's like he found something
concrete this is probably the most
um Supernatural ex someone you know
something religion is a bit of a
supernatural experience if you think
about it right it's got to be you could
say spiritual but you know Jesus in some
ways is the most supernatural being of
them all if an angel appeared to you you
would be like I'm having a supernatural
that is a supernatural experience yeah
exactly and this is probably the closest
he's come to having a real Supernatural
experience and you you see why he's so
gung-ho with his faith on it but I think
the way they made his character uh was
very well done because
uh he's always been like really
interesting to watch I haven't even go
so far to say he's been quite
captivating to watch
but in this time around like I I really
felt like he owned this episode and and
I thought this was actually like a cool
Collision episode everything was like a
Cinematic Universe at the Chucky world
all slapping together here in one they
all converge at this church in some way
shape or form while that was missing in
that one you know the at the altar was
Jennifer Tilly and and uh Glenn being
there that was like the one thing
missing uh but they they do show up at
the end so I thought like getting this
felt like a strong amalgamation of
everything and it felt like this was
going to be the season finale but that's
another reason why I was like where's
the fake out where's the fake out
because we're at the end yet so I'm like
where's the fake out because we're not
at the end when I was like watching this
going
maybe it started having me go like are
they ever gonna do they have a plan to
end Chucky like truly and Chucky this
show or the character in tote in total
uh this episode really made me ponder
that and
um you know having the religious horror
element is is not something far-fetched
considering this whole thing started
with it with a just not Catholicism but
just a different type of religious
belief
and I think having it played into here
was gripping and I thought the way they
shot it was really cool uh it was it was
very as much as they're riffing on The
Exorcist they're not mirroring the shots
of The Exorcist except for one shot but
they're not like overall mirroring the
shots of The Exorcist they're really
doing their own thing and having to be
very candle lit I thought was great uh
yeah I thought this was I thought this
was awesome and
Glenda is you know
it's interesting that it looks like
they're gonna put Glenn in the doll for
survival purposes yeah but Glenda is the
killer between them yeah and and part of
me before the episode was over was like
you know it seems like uh good Chucky
would be the proper sort of role model
for the both of them because she's got
the Killer Instinct a little bit enough
to at least be able to discuss that but
then you know I agree with these
sentences but yeah Glenn is certainly
the more pacifist of the two of them I
feel like uh Glenn has has killed being
egged on by Chucky and has been and
killed by accident in the past but yeah
Glenda is the one who is willing to kill
when the moment calls for it who has
more of her dad's well no both of her
parents instincts really but more of her
dad's like sort of shrewd Edge
um but yeah no it seems like they're
definitely gonna put Glenn's Soul into
the doll again which makes sense you
know I feel like now part of the charm
is not only mutilating the dolls but you
know creating a different show L game of
who's in which doll and which human's
body is that yeah and I think uh Kate
and Andy getting a chance Kyle my bad
said Kitty I said Kate didn't I hate I
meant Kyle Kate
letter name
um
cat
Kyle and Kyle and Andy yeah we got to
kind of uh wrap up on them at least I
don't know like yeah I like that this
felt like this finale because it seemed
like they were really able to go No
Holds Barred and at least they were able
to set you up for something that feels
like it could be an ending and I thought
their wrap up was quite nice together
because for the most part they're just
you know the most experienced Chucky you
know Fighters here and they're mostly
just making sure the plan goes down so
the real you know meat of their presence
this episode is in their little
resolution and I thought the the clip
they chose to pull from Child's Play 2
was a nice one they're always there for
each other yeah and that's what this a
lot of this episode did feel like is
about being there for each other you
know Lexi does pose those questions at
the top of like why are we friends you
didn't have anything in common I'm a
straight drug addict blonde girl you're
two gay guys we have nothing in common
you should well just wait till you get a
little bit older you'll have everything
on each other yes yeah yeah really
positive I might be paraphrasing there
or expanding on yes but I I think that
that at the very end too it's like they
were there for each other and like when
they embrace it it's the thing is
yeah they might not have the most in
common to just talk about other [ __ ]
outside of Chucky but you know at the
end of the day they do really care about
each other and they survive together and
that's the beautiful part about them and
in some ways it's like
they are Our Generations
Kyle and Andy they are well yeah because
they're they're still found family of
each others and and two I was thinking
of the this John yes and now they're all
orphans yes but also I was thinking of
the beginning of the season it's like
they don't you have the distance growing
between Jake and Evan Devin sorry Devin
Evans
Kate and Arthur uh but the two like Lexi
was away from them for a while and the
two of them were having stuff so I feel
like they haven't also just had that
much non-chucky related times since the
first season started well they've been a
lot of focus on a bunch of things that
have been going around you know like
because my last takeaway is like oh yeah
and Jake and uh yeah yeah and and Devin
and Lexi that's right yeah them them
three when like last season I really
thought about them all the time sure and
then here I'm like oh yeah there's like
all these other people that are kind of
more interesting this this season uh the
adults and uh what's the nun
Black Mountain characters you know
everyone's name that's what you do John
you know opposite of sister Ruth Sister
Sister patience or
or piety yeah she's great though and I
love the way that she like
I feel like she will have a big presence
next episode especially but I love the
way she backed up father price oh she
maintains her faith she was like her uh
I like the Harris which one's with the
younger one in The Exorcist
I don't know any other Paris or uh I
don't know her names I have no clue what
what a single name is
um okay
but I like the confession wrap around
too how yes they have to
that like I imagine that's like they
have to do confession before doing the
exorcism it's part of the ritual yeah
you have to cleanse all of our our souls
yeah a fresh slate to exercise someone
that was great that was really great and
then you get to get
um a little more depth with every
character there and see what's
underneath in a way that's like
Exposition earned you know yeah well
yeah and and I mean it I really liked
what they made out of that as a motif
and as a wrap around to the episode
it's easy to have it start out right
there with you oh it's your Tarantino it
was sort of like
this review one man I want everyone to
it we've never been more in harmony
uh but yes
even so far is going to do the whole
like let's give everybody a symbolic
color thing like it was yeah I like the
way this episode managed to be very
stylized in ways that felt subtle and
then in certain moments that felt very
off the wall and very you know
heightened and this is an episode that
exemplifies I think some of my favorite
blending of the two because you have to
say yes I would say that some of the
episodes that we have uh had more
debates over are the ones that lean more
into the height and I would say that
this is one of my favorite episode
episodes of the Season probably and I
think that it found a really nice way to
use the height because especially
through the exorcism scope you can get
crazy in a way that still feels really
dark and really Grim yeah and really
kind of harsh and mean and uh and it's I
think like a secret asset it's like
there's always been that Voodoo element
but here I feel like you're pushing
Chucky into like perhaps the most
Supernatural iteration we've seen it in
so far but it still feels like really
well
in universe and this episode also I
thought really nicely kind of brought
together all of the Just themes of the
setting and the and the reasoning for
setting this here yeah and yeah that
confession wrap around is is great
because it also just reminds you like oh
yeah this is like a great group of
actors who do good work together too
yeah there's a lot of people who need to
let go there's a lot of things about
acceptance but I I liked uh what they
did with Tiffany on the road because
voting her in that 50s vehicle they
decided to tell the her whole story like
it was out of some like B movie sci-fi
horror film yeah just the aesthetic and
mood of it yeah always felt that way
with her character I'm like okay I get
she has the car but they where they
capture the scarf it feels like that yes
I'm like weird like be like a wannabe
it's just like right across it wasn't
made to hitchhikers yeah yeah no no
totally it's a great call
um yeah I thought this was a really
really great episode with a I I I do
wish that and I like the complexity of
Jake feeling you know
uh how he had the good guy how he wanted
to see the good guy in that Chucky yeah
and how he was even like crying at the
end because he was like man
I really thought that I could have
changed this person or brought a good
guy out of the good guy
um but yeah no I think I think every I
think this is a really good Ensemble
episode yeah absolutely everyone really
I think everyone had a moment to shine a
great moment to shine it was one of
those exciting like Cinematic Universe
episodes yeah yeah the big conversions
yeah and that's why I'm like yeah it's
good you brought Nadine back because
everyone deserves a chance in the
spotlight in this episode I thought they
did an excellent job oh yeah totally and
that was a very affecting very beautiful
scene and again after the anger after
the frustration at the end of the last
episode was like no how could you it it
definitely honored it softened that blow
in a way that felt like it also honored
the character and wasn't like cheaping
out so absolutely very pleased for her
and I'm excited to see what the finale
actually becomes because this does feel
like such a finale it ties so many
things together and up we're gonna Last
Jedi that's right there's a big tube oh
yeah that's all I gotta say to upset
someone
The Last Jedi do what does that mean you
know we've seen the Lost Jedi that's
what they did here someone runs up to Dr
mixture and hands her a Chucky doll yeah
all right guys well thanks for being
here
um what do you think about this episode
keep a look out if I think we're
interviewing we're gonna talk to Don
Mancini because I'll let you know I'll
let you personally know yeah um and uh
Hey listen to the patreon
pandemic Jones
pandemic my friend if you were a doll
that came to life I would never exercise
you out of that doll even if you wanted
to be you're trapped listen dude you've
been part of our patreon page for 30
months almost that's almost half a year
that's almost a few years two years two
and a half years you've been here for 30
weeks 30 months that's insane dude
um listen if I do the math correctly
here
that's like six hundred dollars
that's that's how does that make you
feel yes right uh yeah that makes me
feel but does that make you feel good
yeah as a lump investment how do you
feel over this much time you get to
write us off or be a charity investment
for you yes in all seriousness dude uh
thank you for being here for the amount
of time you've been here I hope you have
a wonderful Thanksgiving you know that
you are one of the people that we are
grateful for
because of the six hundred dollars yes
mostly that we just look at your
contribution and we see that number and
we just kind of thank you for being 600
thank you for being here we love you 600
I really love you
I know we love you infinitely then and
you are just a really sweet guy so thank
you for mainly being that otherwise I
would I've done it I've booted out
patrons before I've literally sent
messages to be like hey I'm sending you
a refund I don't like you don't break
that energy here again that a couple
times I just gotta do it man
so thank you for being awesome
[Music]